near yoki Oh is the greatest city in the
world it is a diverse labyrinth of
cultural and architectural innovation of
course whenever city becomes the envy of
the world she's possessed a sucks
problems are bound to arise Gascon we
need to discuss a matter of national
security we've seen a dramatic rise in
occult activity you have a sacred duty
to protect the city as well as our
family name I told you to clear my
schedule I'm grieving the death of a
relationship oh dear
[Music]
don't you understand you need to perk to
support your wretched lifestyle
look it's new yoyo Joe's second most
eligible bachelor yo we gotta teach you
all money [ __ ] boys a lesson
you can't give Arcangelo to satisfaction
be when lose we'll all be equal in the
grave I'm surprised you don't wear more
black calves aren't you prone to
melancholy I wouldn't say that I have a
generally cheerful disposition
hi guys ameer slayer of demons I can see
you [ __ ] you're wearing a black tuxedo
against a midnight blue sky and it's
sparkling the city's on high alert it's
a perfect storm Coco Chanel may her
memory be blessed can you feel the
synergy caz no I feel no synergy
[Music]
you